Hello everyone and welcome back to the coverage of the Jerusalem Fida grand prix
2019 it's way Everson's an expiry two of their classical games have ended in a draw and the first rapid game ended in a draw
so this is the second game of the rapids where we has the white pieces and
Well, everything about this game is interesting. It features are really weird opening a really cool middle game and
Most important of all that there's no end game so a bit of a spoiler there
But I'm sure you're gonna agree that it doesn't matter and we do have a nice photo of this matchup
Here it is. Even though it's from the first rapid game where gear we had the white pieces, but we don't have
Still a photo from the second rapid game in the background there. You see the blurry nipple battling it out with with Boris Gelfand
So that being said, let's check out the game wayy with the white pieces opens with E 4
We have c5 the Sicilian defense and here we have Bishop to e2 the so-called slow variation
which
Well, it's very flexible that
Goes without saying but on the other hand it allows the black pretty much to do whatever black ones
So we have nice to see six by Giri with f4 by way and the immediate d5
So already black achieves the dream executed e5 in the Sicilian
But it's one of the one of the well not nicer things about playing this variation
Now we have d3 and now Giri doesn't want to trade characters characters and trade queens
Instead he goes for g6. Just continuous development. Now we have knight to f3
Knight to f6 and now e5 pushing the knight back
and here wethere is a game where Knight to g8 was played and night to
G4 is a known move. But the Giri goes for Knight to h5 his 80s
He wants the ribbon over the Knight to g7 and then TSX to put pressure on f4
And it is already as of move 6 that we have a completely new game something that does not happen very often often
especially in elite chess
We have castles by Wei Yi and Knight back to g7?
We have Bishop to e3 continuing development now d4 an important move as you want to
Move the bishop away from the defense of the f4 point
So knife the e6 comes with a threat so Bishop to f2 and the now Knight the e6 putting pressure on f4
So we defense it and the Bishop to g7 now
Everything is ready for Geary to castle. We have Knight B to d2 now after black black advance the pawn to d4
He weakened d4 in c4 square
so perhaps wife can use that to get a better a central square for his Knight with castles by black and the now c3
Just the challenging black center and black does the same with a f6 challenging white strong center with eke a press-on
f6e captures on f6 and now Queen to b3 putting pressure along side this diagonal and also
Making it somewhat difficult for whites to develop the light square bishop. So we have Quinta
h8 immediately unpinning and rook F to e 1 with
B6 now
The b-pawn will no longer be a target and now Bishop to f1
Black will probably develop the lights for a bishop on this diagonal. So white will
probably do the same to counter the effects of the dark square bishop with D captures and c3b captures and
Night to c7 now now black a giri decides that he wants to develop the bishop this way
Which will come with an attack on the Queen and then the knight can maybe come to d5?
We have rook a to d1 and now comes the shock to e6
just attacking the Queen and
Asking well asking the way do you perhaps want to capture on e6? And
If you capture on e6
You get nice the a5 that's the problem. You take away the Queen from the defense of the rook
So the Queen will not be able to stay on this diagonal the Queen has to move and then you pick up the rook so
after this Queen to be to move
After Bishop thesis we have Queen to be to just getting the Queen out of the way and now Queen to d7
Preparing to bring the other look into the game with d4
And now C characters on d4 with Knight captures on d4 Knight captures and Bishop captures and here
Bishop to g4 putting pressure on the rook here
Black would really enjoy if white moves the roof from the default and black and just completely owned the D file
descriptor e to
countering
Black's like lights work this up and now rook 88 and if you look at this position
Sorry rook 8e a if you look at this position
It's a it is a complicated position a lot of pieces on the board. Both players still have the bishop pair
And most of all white has to isolate his bones
So the a pawn and the C pawn, however, the C pawn, although it's not a very strong pawn
It will do wonders guarding the bishop on d4
So if white gets to keep the bishop on d4 that Bishop is just a monster controlling the entire board
So Bishop captures in g4 we have Queen Catherine g4 and now Knight to c4
We have nice the d5 by giri and here comes Queen to f2 now Knight to d5
It's an excellent square for the knight
But it also comes with the threat of just knife captures on f4 as the G point spend so Queen to f2
Defending if black should capture and now rook to d8
getting getting out of the
detention here and now comes Luke the d3 with ideas of maybe doubling groke on the D file, but also just
Adding another defender to the 3rd the rank we have look after I ate and now comes a very creative move by way E
Which starts an avalanche of crazy ideas?
Knight to d6, which is just
Well asking black. What do you wanna do? Your rook is under attack and it's under attack twice
So here Gary trades once with rook captures Queen captures and now okay
You cannot capture the night because it is just meeting to check their blocks. And then this is mate
So you replace?
King to g8 and now rook captures and e6 is a threat because after let's say and well not that but after the Queen checks
Now you can block Bishop f8 because the king guards the bishop
And here comes Knight to e8 and here is where the magic happens now the bishop is under attack
so if you eliminate this Bishop, then nothing will be able to oppose a white light/white dark square bishop and
Well, it's not easy to find a move here for black especially for giri who is very low on time
So just to point out how many things can go wrong?
If you try something like Bishop to f8 seems like a reasonable idea, you know white will be unable to capture your bishop
Also you have in mind maybe something like rule d7 rook e8 to pick up the night here
But the problem is white has Bishop captures and b6 seems like weird move, you know
Like nothing is happening on the queenside. What's the point of this?
The point is if the bishop is captured you play rook captures on d5, and you've eliminated all the defenders of the f6 pawn
So now you don't really have a move
It's just a loss for black and of course if you capture then it's a monster for key
the queen king and rook are forked and
There's nothing to do here for black
but there was a move where giri
In this position that giri could have improved his position. It's a hidden move and
Well now that I've told you about
what all the
You know all the poison lurks in the position
I'm sure you would have found it by now, but its Queen to f5 the point
Is that now Yuri maneuvered the Queen away from the dangerous g4 square?
So in the future the knight captors on f6 will not be
Capturing the Queen and you don't lose time doing it because the rook on d3 is under attack
So once the rook moves then you go Bishop to f8 and now black is even better. So this is a slight improvement
for gearing the position, although it's unrealistic to
Say that it was in the position since it's a rapid game gear
It was very low on time and you have to play something
So here get replayed an even better move well or so he thought he played Knight captures on f4 and it seems reasonable
Well, the the knight cannot be captured the pawn is pinned. The rook is under attack Knight to h3
Also is coming. So it's a definitely a great move, but it loses the game
So feel free to pause the video and try to find why it loses the game while I give you a couple of seconds
So for those of you who were able to do it
Congratulations
and
Figuring out that the knight on d5 was a really important piece because it was covering the e7 square
And for those of you who just want to enjoy the show
it's Queen to e7 when the knight captured an f4 it lost the control of the e7 square and now
Just Queen captures in g7 is the threat of checkmate and the giri continued with Knight to h3 check, but just to show you
Eliminating the three a threat of meat by removing the night. It doesn't really help black after Bishop
Covers with Bishop to f8 you get a rookie three
Now you control the e2 square twice and there's no way to wiggle out of this one
If you go now - to recheck just King g2 if Knight f4 check now you move back King f2 and now if Knight h3
Check once again King II 1 and here
black is really without any compensation for the force for the
You know
Sacrificed exchange and after let's say queen a5 threatening to go for some queen f to check ideas
Or maybe queen to be one to harass the White Queen King just Queen e6 check
Exchanges here and you don't really have compensation. Yes, you are up upon but a rook is a look
So white white will be winning this game without a problem. So after Queen to e7
First we discussed the rook captures and it doesn't work and now Knight to h3. This is what gear we played
we have Quinta f1 and now Queen to
f1 with check
Now with idea of coming to f2, but now King to g2 now Queen f2 check is just met with King captures on h3
Sorry, the Queen can't even come to F 2 so it's not even a threat
Forgot about our good friend of the bishop here and here rook to d7. You have to guard against mate
so once again pause the video here and try to find the incredible variation the only line that wins this for white and
Well, one of the bigger reasons why I decided to show you this game
Well, I give you a couple of seconds so
For those of you who are able to do it
Congratulations on finding this incredible line that features a temporary Queen sacrifice
and for those who who just want to enjoy show its Knight captures on f6
This comes with check, of course
You cannot capture with the Queen because you lose the Queen so the shop characters on f6 and now Queen
Th check leaving black with only one move that one move is King to g7 and now comes the movie had to find
I'm just gonna give you a few more seconds to spot this one because it you know from that position
It's not an easy line to find
But you know
Congratulations to everyone who found it. It's Queen captures on d7 and
Believe it or not. It was in this position unmoved 36 that onigiri resigned the game as
There is nothing more to be done here if the Queen is accepted then Bishop captures on f6 with check
Well king captures and the rook captures and e7 leaves you with this terrible end game
Which is very easily winning you you have to save the knight then real capture
Sunday 7 next you're gonna capture this point as well
and this is completely winning for white and
The other option is to not accept the Queen is to just move the King from check
But this this is even worse because Queen captures now
You have to capture the Queen back now Bishop captures on f6
you are up a whole rook and again if Knight g5 just trade down into a young Gustav's on endgame where one player has a
rook and the other player doesn't so Queen captures and d7 with check very impressive stuff and well, it's just
Just one one icer ways to win a game that I've seen in quite a while in top tier chess
So yeah with this loss initially is eliminated from the feeder grand prix
like I said
Two of the classical games would run then the first rapid game was drawn and then the second game was won by wayy
So that's it for any giri and the way he advances to the you know, upper floors of the of the tournament
so I do hope you enjoyed it and
Yeah, that that's pretty much it. I would like to thank Paul Bunton and Sven FOIA for a contributor to my channel
Thank you. A lot - really appreciate it as usual. You can check to my previous video serum
Thank you for watching and I will see you soon, continuing the coverage of the feeder Grand Prix 2019 the last leg of it
Continue to check up on your wonderful suggestions. And of course whatever else happens in the chess world
So thank you all I will see you soon and have an excellent rest of your day and do be a part of the subscribers
video
Thank you. I will see soon and have an excellent rest of your day
Alright, perhaps I said that twice but you know still have an excellent rest, really